welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars and or episode one I am loving this
Rogue one prequel series for its
grounded depiction of the Star Wars
Universe like being unafraid to open in
a brothel no grogu's allowed in here
though considering the young liens who
kicked off the last Star Wars show kids
might be safer in this one I am going to
break down all the Star Wars Easter eggs
and the subtle details that make this
show so great and thanks to boxu for
sponsoring this video more on their
tasty offerings later so every Star Wars
Disney plus title opens with a red and
blue lit series of familiar Droid faces
and metallic helmets this one is updated
to include b2emo or B2 the ground Mech
Salvage assist unit new to this series
The Andor title card shows an eclipse in
Space the Crescent of that planet
becoming a rudimentary version of the
Rebel Alliance symbol representing
Cassian andorra's Evolution from an
undefined Planet Hopper to a fully
fledged Rebel Soldier we open on the
Rainy planet of morlana 1 where the
title lists the year as five BBY now if
you've been following Star Wars you know
that BBY and apy stand for before the
battle we have in and after the battle
of Yavin in this case five years before
the events of A New Hope and Rogue one
what's interesting here is that this is
the first time where BBY has actually
been used on screen in a Star Wars show
or movie BBY and ABY have certainly been
used among fans and the new essential
chronology reference book from 2005
suggested some in-universe characters
use the Battle of Yavin as a kind of
calendar year zero but Star Wars has
never until now actually shown the
letters BBY on screen but this series is
clearly trying to match Rogue one which
did use on-screen titles for locations
and this Rogue one prequel series is
essentially a ticking clock toward that
battle pre-ox morlana is the name of a
private Corporation contracted by the
Empire to oversee this system and run
their security internally kind of like
the Wayland yutani Corporation from the
alien franchise Grandma Tarkin had kind
of a smug Outlook that was all about
delegation how just the fear of the
Death Star and the regional Governors
would keep everyone in line This is
extension of that they're literally
Contracting their security out to a
private company now all this rain over
the walkway lamps the amazing synthes
score from composer Nicholas Patel the
security Hovercraft in the background
with their searchlights all of this
gives off a nourished cyberpunk feel
akin to Blade Runner which is also the
influence of the Rings of caprine and
cassian's intro scene in Rogue one
Cassian passes these display bubbles
with some folks to have some fun with
folks to maybe fight or to bet on in the
background you can hear a female worker
saying my credit
No Nonsense yeah that sounds a lot like
the voice of the freaking Midwife Droid
on polis Masa in Revenge of the Sith
according to starwars.com it's kind of a
comforting cooing sound so one of these
morlana workers is pitching themselves
with the warm bedside manner of an OB
GYN that'd be
that'd be so hard on you baby let's
relax and
inside some Hollow projectors beam a
dancer reminding this Apollo projected
Twilight dancer watched by the partisans
on jet hunt Rogue one so Cassian is
looking for a girl from kinari but the
hostess says that they have a girl from
tahina who she says has those big dark
eyes that you're looking for both
planets are new to Star Wars and the
suggestion really is that people from
qunari and tahina have dark features
Cassian asked for the name of the canary
girl that the hostess had seen and the
hostess says nobody here gives their
real name an interesting stated theme
for this series this will be a show
about deceit people's declared
identities are rarely who they really
are the two cops kravis and verlo Chase
down Cassian because this is an employee
only area off limits to people not on
the corporate payroll this whole idea of
company towns is also explored in Loki
with the Roxanne owned Haven Hills
Alabama a bit of biting the hand by
directors on this platform that's owned
by a studio that essentially runs
company towns with their own legal
jurisdictions they ask when he swallow
swim over scroll now yes surrounded by
water in literal bubbles in this opening
sequence frames Cassian as a
metaphorical at least evolutionary
amphibian transitioning from sea to land
the guy really has been adrift in an
ocean and he's now on a hero's journey
to walk a path after wrestling a blaster
from their hands Cassian says tell me
what to do
let's hear it North another Motif
throughout this episode pretty much
every scene ends with the character
telling Cassian exactly what to do make
yourself useful now go fix your
finish up get out
don't come back he's still a Wanderer
who needs this direction now verlo
doesn't get up and crevice says
that Thunderclap was kind of a thought
of realization for kravis don't make a
guy feel like he has no other way out
when he is still holding the gun on you
but Grava still tries we played too hard
for him and you didn't understand it I'm
trying to grab you in but he fell and he
said
we're going together
I'll tell you what happened
story of what really happened this
tactic comes up throughout the episode
for many characters specifically Cassian
later uses this with Brasso there are
two guys conspiring on an alternate
version of the night before his events
it's almost like Cassian gets this from
the Sentry and on to the planet farrix
this is actually part of the same system
as morlani one its name is likely based
on the term param the Latin word for
iron which is why it's chemical symbols
Fe kids
which reflects the rusty color of this
planet the way the ground is just rusty
red and all the scrap metal of these
Clone Wars era ships being broken apart
to build a new Fleet for the Empire the
town of Ferris is actually a practical
set constructed in a former Quarry in
the UK town of Little Merlot and
buckinghamshire giving these actors a
full town to walk around in as opposed
to the LED screens of the volume that's
been used in other Star Wars live action
Productions our new favorite Droid of
b2emo rolls past a building with orbash
translating to Barracks D something and
then beneath Speeders available in
episode 3 this will be the building
where they hijack those Speeders to get
away B2 stops
foreign
these bores look like they played
backboard this is from the Star Wars
Galaxies game B2 rolls up to sleeping
Cassian on the ship that he took to
morlani one now parked in the shipyard
I brought what you to told me
gassian
casa
so B2 is voiced with an adorable stutter
by Dave Chapman a long time voice actor
who actually puppeteered bb-8 but in
this show they usually let the people
who Puppeteer the character also voice
the character now we don't know what's
in this scene B2 actually calls Cassian
Casa or Cassian hears the voice of the
Droid in his dream calling him what his
sister Carrie called him this flashback
shows the planet of qunari where a
Riverside tribe of youths react to a
republic era vessel crashing into her
head and I say Republic because if Andor
is set in 5 BBY anything before 14 years
prior to that would be Clone Wars era or
earlier that was before the Republic
gave way to the Empire notice as that
ship crashes a secondary explosion
releases a trail of Yellow Smoke clue
that it was a kind of chemical bomb that
caused this crash now I have heard from
a bunch of new rock stars viewers that
have already signed up for baksu but for
the uninitiated baksu is a monthly
subscription service that delivers
premium Japanese snacks and tea periods
straight from Japan to your door they
Source rare snacks from all over the
country and partner with family business
is to make their own signature treats
all of these are curated and delivered
under a new theme every month and this
month's theme is
Matsuri nights so the Matsuri Knights
box is custom built to take the magical
feeling of wandering through a Japanese
festival at night time and pack it into
a box and here's the thing they nailed
it I'm gonna try the Ido Matsuri
ningyoyaki cake it's a doll shaped cake
baked in a small iron mold and filled
with custard mine is in the shape of a
Taiko drum oh my God this is good can I
get a whole box of just these it's so
sweet but not like overly sweet it's
just kind of satisfying I could eat a
thousand of these easy and the nice
thing about baksu is that when you
really fall in love with the boxu snack
you can order some direct from their
site at a discount both I and the new
Rockstar's office have been receiving
these boxes for ages and we love them
I've seen some pics from around the
office during unboxing and it's wild how
excited everyone gets plus every time
you get your box two in the mail you can
feel good knowing that you are
supporting family businesses all the way
in Japan so if you want to try some rare
Japanese snacks with us and support the
channel click the link in the
description and use the code rockstars
to get 15 off your order oh my God one
girl tries to Signal it before another
shuts her up now the leader is credited
in the credits is Alpha One the shouting
girl is Alpha 4 and we don't really have
any other name for them than Alphas for
now just an interesting choice to have
these qunari kids speak to each other
without subtitles now we obviously don't
need the translation we can figure out
what they're talking about based on the
context but the rare choice in Star Wars
to not translate what people are saying
keeps Cassian in his past at a bit of
distance for the viewer like the camera
could be that of a documentarian
embedded with these refugees just along
for the ride and requiring us to just
take all this in without any judgment
Cassian wakes up and asks me too about
who came asking for him while he was out
pausing for a data lag oh this poor beat
up old-timer and Cassian later asks him
to lie I can lie I have adequate power
reserves I love it it takes the Droid
extra power to lie it's just a really
cool commentary on how it really takes
humans more energy to lie than to just
be honest as Cassian walks into town the
camera lingers on the town's Bell Tower
which we will see in future episodes
striking metal is a key way that these
workers tell time and communicate in
other ways beneath the bell tower we
could see a bulky alien walking with
industrial yellow plating on its head
and back maybe an exoskeleton to lift
scrap metal we see dozens of pairs of
worker gloves hanging from a wall kind
of like punch cards for these workers to
check in but there's a few empty slots
maybe some who died recently on the job
cassia tells Brasso to tell people that
they spent the night together drinking
nog nog and revnog come up a few times
in this series sounds like an
in-universe term for homemade booze but
Brasso agrees by adding the cassian's
big story to include a fake part
explaining why casting would have a
bruise on his cheek notice how pretty
much everyone Cassian talks to also
comments on his injury just a reminder
that in this empire-dominated Society
any change in the routine gets noticed
and must have a cover story behind it
back in Orlando one Deputy inspector
Cyril Karn makes a detailed report on
those murders have you modified your
uniform
perhaps slightly
Pockets piping
some light
tailoring I love commenting on an
officer's uniform in Star Wars because
yeah that suit fits tight around his
core and waist on Chief Hinds screen the
orabesh on the second line translates to
pharynx so the answer to Karns inquiry
was actually right there on that screen
but Hein tells car not to pursue it to
Dedicated primor employees caught in the
saddle bit of a Calamity but they were
murdered no they were killed in a fight
it's a third time characters try to
concoct a false narrative out of
convenience Hein is on his way to
Imperial inspection and doesn't want to
have to report a recent crime we see how
this era is giving all the people a
strained relationship with the truth
back on Barracks Cassian approaches a
shot with orabesh on the front including
the words conversion codes big detaches
supports this looks like Pod racer
engine her welding mask looks like the
piece of a Droid head Cassian tellsbeck
said he wants to sell her high profile
contact a valuable part I got an
untraceable ns9 star breath unit
Vector crystals and Imperial seal still
intact this is an imperial navigator
that shows locations in the channels
that the imps used to get from place to
place vix's partner says
tomorrow oh Bonnie is the location of
the Imperial prison where jyn urso is
detained in Rogue one wobani is actually
an anagram for Obi-Wan sounds like these
salesman bid on Scrapper runs to other
planets getting in on Whatever Gets
found kinda like Storage Wars I love how
much we're learning about the low-level
economy of this Society right now back
on qunari the alphas see more Yellow
Smoke rising from that crash site they
stir darts and poison prepping some blow
dark guns and these Lord of the Flies
kids streaked their arms and faces in
Ash as the kind of war paint back at the
present Karn makes an astrotra traffic
control officer kind of like an air
traffic control operator check the
charts in the night before the junior
officer speculates that the unknown
Cruiser could be an Orleans Star cab or
a Davin Orlin star cabs are old scout
vessels that are mentioned in the
guidebook in the 90s role-playing game
Cassian gets stopped by nirchi who uses
bench to try to intimidate
cassians
yeah the actor who plays the patches Ian
white the actor who plays the Giant 1-1
in Game of Thrones the guy is seven foot
one and again I love that they let white
physically play the part and voice the
character meanwhile the orbash on the
shot behind them reads screens as Tim
tries to follow Bix he loses her near a
sign norbesh that reads Droid parts and
above that from the opposite angle you
can see it reads Service as Bix passes a
gonk Droid and on that Droid shop wall
hang a few legs of protocol droids also
as Tim looks around there's another
parts shop sign in a different language
this looks like at least now haties
maybe something else I just like that
not all the signs are in orabesh to show
the diversity of races that live here
Bix walks into a repair shop repair in
the orbash there but also out front
hangs a bell or wind chime something
later that the proprietor Solomon pack
will use to clang to Signal other Town's
people to act Bix asks for a mending
match Tech filter bending being a
Starcraft company in universe that made
the xr12 but really this is the kind of
code between Bix and salmon for a
communicator hidden in the cylinder
column and she communicates by flipping
a series of switches to release her a
rhythmic beeping kind of like an Indian
versus Morse code an Intel officer on
morelana 1 eats a mouthful of blue Ramen
ah the Star Wars tradition of randomly
blue food they reference an imperial
census that was done six years prior so
if this is by BBY that census would have
been an 11 BBY or eight years after the
Imperial takeover and another officer
warns about cracking down too hard on
Barracks they have their own way of
doing things I love all these little
examples we're getting this air of Star
Wars about how hard it is to have any
authority over all of these diverse
planets and Societies in the shipyard
Cassian gets chewed out by the guard
pegla played by Kieran O'Brien AKA James
tart and Ted lasso Jamie tart's a-hole
dad his boss zorbi barks over the PA
what in the name of trump is going on
there shop so jobs knob is an expletive
used by bit in the heir to the Jedi
novel and we learned that peglin knows
Cassian is switching out chip logs and
he knows that Cassian used this for
something Shady we end the episode back
in that qunari flashback where Cassian
leaves his sister behind
yeah that clacking percussion
intensifies as we cut to black as if to
say cassian's final glance at his sister
is what hits him the hardest since they
released the first three episodes all at
once my breakdowns of episode 2 and
episode 3 are gonna be up on the channel
very soon you can follow me on Tick Tock
Instagram and Twitter at avos follow me
rockstars subscribe ninja rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]